all right I want to bring up a graphic
here I actually cited this on TV
yesterday too because I think it's
really I think it's a really interesting
graphic this is from Coveney this is a
US share of global R&D investment 1967
as you can see right here it was a
little over 60% a big chunk of that was
DoD related obviously the USSR also made
up a significant size of the global
total and as you see it move through the
next several decades then over the next
50 years you get to 2017 and the u.s. is
less than 3% of global R&D spending and
look at what's happened with China it's
completely it's jumped and it's become a
larger share of the global total than
the USSR was during the Cold War we were
having this question before we got on
stage and Peter I'll send it back over
to you how much is the need for new
innovation new technologies the way
you're thinking about funding companies
and starting companies right now how
much is that being driven by the China
discussion well I think the China
dynamic has changed things tremendously
in the last few years where we're you
know the 90s and maybe still in the
2000s we thought the Cold War was over
and there was sort of a there was sort
of a way we could proceed on where could
be slower you could you go with the
bigger the bigger primes things like
this I think you know I think China is
going to force us to compete to think
much harder how we can deploy
technologies much faster and and and and
so I think I think it's just it changed
the dynamic tremendously I think we have
a serious space race with China we have
you know we have a serious a I race you
know I've I've complained in the past
about Google's you know but I think very
problematic decision to pull out on the
MIT project maven the AI project with
the US military and to continue to work
with China which i think is sort of a
shocking unprecedent thing for a Mei
American company not to work with the US
but indirectly to work with our
geopolitical rivals
military but I think sort of the the
silver lining of the Maven controversy
is that it it tells us that AI is a
military technologies or at least it's a
dual use technology and it's not
something that Silicon Valley had
acknowledged for a long time for you
know and I think it's sort of very
different think about the debate we had
about nuclear weapons in the in the
1940s what was clear it was dual use and
you had a debate and there were
scientists like Oppenheimer who were
against Aunt Eller or favor and because
of a debate and we haven't had this
debate and I think I think even though I
disagree with Google and project maven
and I think it has forced a debate and
and that's that sort of debate about AI
is gonna happen in many other areas of
technology they are dual use and you
know it's we better make sure we get the
cutting-edge ones on our side do you
think Silicon Valley or the rest of
Silicon Valley who's woken up to that
factor do you think that's a Google
specific situation or do you think it's
a bigger broader issue debate it's
certainly been framed around this idea
of ethics for example employees not
wanting to work on military related
projects do you think it's Google
specific or do you think it's more of a
bigger broader culture you know there's
there things are specific to Google
there are things that are that are more
general in Silicon Valley where it has
sort of law it's very disconnected from
the history of the 1950s and 1960s where
Silicon Valley was heavily created by by
military R&D and people are just not
aware of that history in any way
I think the Seattle companies Amazon
Microsoft are probably somehow better
than the Silicon Valley companies on
this and that the sort of so there's
some cultural differences between
Seattle and Silicon Valley but but you
know even even in Silicon Valley you
talk to people and there is sort of a
recognition to some things very
different I would I would push back on
the ethical framing I think you know I
think that when it's a choice between
the US and China it is always the
ethical decision to work with the US
government and and it's very even though
we don't know all the unethical things
they're going in China they're sort of
often hidden and
that's that's that's a much more
problematic ethical one and so it's
really odd that we're having any sort of
debate where where that's even even
framed as a question just coming back to
the Rd chart you had earlier you know I
don't think it's necessary for the US
military to go back to doing 30% of the
R&D spend globally agree but you know if
we're not going to do that we have to
reform the procurement process so it's
okay for us to outsource the part of the
R&D to you know to venture capital to
Silicon Valley to other parts of the
private sector but but that's only going
to work if the procurement process gets
reformed and and then there's a pathway
for this to happen there's no shortage
of there's no shortage of venture
capital generally you know we live in a
world where central banks have been
printing money for 10 years we have 20
trillion dollars of bonds that have
negative yields there's no shortage of
venture capital but but there is not
that much being put into into sort of
military defense companies because we
all have this look-ahead function where
it's it's gonna be slow if it's dual use
you know well we better focus on the
commercial we don't know how fast the
military will happen and it's like
always this race you know if you can get
something in six months on the
commercial side and military side might
take three years even if you get it down
to two years you're still gonna focus on
the commercial side and so there's all
so I think you know I think Silicon
Valley it's not just ideological or
myopic there is a certain part of it
where it's a rational look ahead
function the people have all right we've
got a couple of questions here let's see
if we can get through them all could
larger traditional defense Prime's just
acquire startups this is a good question
to harness their tech in human capital
much like other big tech companies such
as Google do with startups all these
advantages larger scale companies have
when I when I started PayPal years ago a
very different context there was always
asked why can't a big bank just do this
and I'd never had a good answer to that
because in theories the banks have
scaled they can have longer time
horizons they have more capital they've
a lot of talent and I think I think the
general answer is that it's just the
internal politics are unbelievably bad
and this and this is true not just of
you know large parts of the government
it's also true of a lot of large
corporations become in
incredibly politicized in ways that are
not good for innovation so I think you
can acquire a technology company at that
point where you don't need to innovate
anymore so so so if it's a if it's a
fully formed thing maybe that's that's a
point of which you it makes sense for
the primes to acquire them but if you
still need to maintain that culture of
innovation that's gonna be very hard to
do